i took the issue of media freedom very  seriously it is one of the building  blocks of our democracy however  i share the views expressed by a wide  range of members including i believe the  prime minister that yesterday's article  was reporting substantiated claims of  misogynistic and defensive  those are what we believe i expressed my  sympathy to write about member for  ashton delaware subject to this type of  comment in being demeaning offensive to  women in parliament it can only deter  women who might be considering standing  for election  to the detriment of us all  that is why i am arranging meeting with  the chair of the press lobby the editors  of the mail on sunday to discuss the  issue affecting our parliamentary  community i will i'm also arranging  separately and i believe we've now got a  time where i will be meeting the right  old member flashed on the line this  evening